buenas tardes buenas noches aquí soy
steve en vancouver en canadá y voy a
hablar el castellano
en español porque las semanas pasadas se
ha hablado
chino indistinto de idiomas chino
japonés ruso francés alemán
pues y siempre sobre el mismo tema del
aprendizaje de idiomas
la gente aquí en youtube que me sigue
que se queja que yo siempre hablo del
mismo tema
y no solo yo pero otros políglotas
siempre hablan de esto hoy y no son
capaces de hablar de otra cosa pero a
veces es una tontería
pues voy a hablar también de yo no sé el
conflicto entre gibraltar y
y españa
los acontecimientos en egipto o lo que
sea pero yo creo que la mayoría de la
mayoría de la gente quiere escuchar mi
opinión sobre el aprendizaje de idiomas
que voy a hablar bueno
el internet es un mundo
maravilloso
para mí para aprender idiomas no
necesitas ir
a clase necesitas el aula puedes puedes
bien puede ser si hay un profesor
estupendo y bueno puede ser muy útil
útil pero no es necesario porque hay
tantos recursos en el internet hay
libros hay audio de todo todo tipos
podcast blogs blogs hay recursos sobre
la gramática o yo puedo buscar la
conjugación de cualquier verbo en
francés español yo no sé ruso ya que
todo está
disponible
y también hay esos políglotas como yo y
otros que de bueno dan consejos sobre el
aprendizaje
de idiomas
debo decir que voy a hablar español pero
es un idioma que hablo muy muy poco
porque los últimos años
aprendí estoy aprendiendo ruso corro
menos coreano y habló mucho en chino
también aquí en verde
y es muy raro que tengo la ocasión de
hablar español nunca he vivido en españa
he visitado a españa 10 veces cada vez
de una semana dos semanas entonces es
seguro que voy a cometer errores voy
confundir con portugués con italiano con
romero con
y otros idiomas
pero
y debo decir que para refrescarme un
poco para que este vídeo
he buscado podcast muy interesantes en
español por ejemplo los podcast de la
cope es una cadena de radio un poco a la
derecha pero también he buscado podcast
de la radio nacional de españa españa
que es más o menos a la izquierda
entonces yo escucho esos podcast o para
el mensaje político pero porque éste me
permite de refrescar mis conocimientos y
mis habilidades en español
un tema que quiero discutir es la
importancia de este aprendizaje
que parece muy pasivo es decir la
escucha y la lectura pero es muy muy
importante es muy importante cuando
empecemos para acumular vocabulario para
acostumbrarse al idioma se puede hacer
mucho en mi caso por ejemplo aprendiendo
ruso yo
pase yo no sé un año sin hablar
escuchando y leyendo leyendo y
acumulando vocabulario y permitiendo a
mi cerebro de ser acostumbrar a este
idioma porque cuando empezamos pues
el idioma extranjero es únicamente ruido
no entendemos nada y no sabemos dónde
termina una palabra y dónde empieza la
siguiente pues hay que acostumbrarse
por eso yo no creo que podemos empezar a
hablar y muchas veces en las aulas hay
hay un esfuerzo
me parece irracional sobre la producción
la producción del idioma la probidad va
a llegar va a llegar pero para al
principio no al principio hay que
acostumbrarse y las las explicaciones de
gramática son muy muy difíciles si
nosotros no tenemos una experiencia con
el idioma porque sí sí yo sobre todo en
idiomas como en español también el
subjuntivo
el conjuntivo es un concepto que no
tenemos en inglés ahora quizás antes y
pues sin una referencia a unas
experiencias
cosas que yo he vivido en mi lectura
pues las reglas no tienen normas de
sentido entonces este
el aprendizaje pasivo es muy muy
importante este es a la base de lo que
hemos hecho en el lic online que es un
manera muy eficaz de aprender de textos
y hay siempre el audio y el texto bueno
pero una vez
llegado a un cierto nivel hay que hablar
para hablar bien hay que hablar mucho
mucho mucho mucho pero no tienes que
empezar al principio porque al principio
tú no tienes nada que decir no tú no
tienes palabras no tú no vas a
comprender y entender lo que dice el
otro entonces es muy importante trabajar
este
acreditar el vocabulario y después una
vez que tienes la confianza hay que
hablar pero hay al otro lado hay gente
que el de jane bien que es que entienden
que creen que puedo comprender puedo
entender
estoy leyendo libros pero bueno dicen
esto no es siempre el caso pero dice que
comprende bien pero tienen miedo de
hablar
porque quieren ser perfectos tienen
miedo de cometer errores gramaticales
pero este este es una tontería porque si
tú no vas a cometer errores tú no vas a
mejorar solamente cometiendo errores
tú vas a descubrir dónde son tus
problemas y este bueno el profesor puede
corregir te pero muchas veces tú debes
hablando y escuchando uniendo tú vas a
dar cuenta de dónde están tus lagunas
donde están los problemas
es por eso que es muy importante hablar
y comunicar porque finalmente aprendemos
los idiomas para comunicarnos no para no
es una competición
es mejor o menos bien que el otro no es
de este nuevo es importante para nada yo
he trabajado en mi vida 45 años en el
comercio internacional con gente de
todos los países
la mayoría de tiempo hablamos inglés y
todos hablan con errores con acentos que
todo es importante pero el vocabulario
es importante porque si tú no tienes
palabras tú no puedes decir nada y el
comprensión si tú no entiendes lo que
dice
el otro pues era muy difícil pero
situamos con errores con acento es menos
importante
y bueno entonces es puede parecer un
poco contradictorio que para aprender el
aprendizaje pasivo que tú puedes hacer
tú mismo utilizando los recursos del
internet escuchando leyendo utilizando
sistemas en el ínter internet como link
buscando recursos sobre la gramática
todo esto puedes hacerlo tú mismo
entonces
hay que ponerse independiente no pero
tan importante que sea por tan
importante que sea está este aprendizaje
recibo finalmente llegado la hora de
hablar hay que hablar y hay que hablar
mucho pero esto se puede hacer a través
de internet a través de skype puedes
buscar amigos hay tan tantos sitios de
intercambios de idiomas que puedes
buscar gente con quien puedes cambiar el
inglés español de todo entonces llegado
este momento hay que hay que hablar y
hay que hablar mucho bueno este es lo
que quería quería decir sí
vosotros tenéis preguntas por favor voy
a entrar de contestar aquí en los
comentarios
muchas gracias y hasta luego